the dark side Palpatine read test we
couldn't watch this final trailer for
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker got our
tickets already catch us at an IMAX
located in the valley of Los Angeles
which one well stop him and you might
find us let's get into this shall we
the Wills the helmet
[Music]
feeling
together
Disney's Jungle Cruise
[Music]
we're gonna use the camera it
Wow
[Music]
have a whaling come in here
I gotta get that closed down taking one
last look
wha-what-what 3px
[Music]
you
[Music]
this is so epic
[Music]
mostly with you she's definitely gonna
Palpatine there whoa hey whoa this is
like a frame-by-frame thing whoo-whee
he'll look we gotta do a whole breakdown
[Music]
yo yo watch it again
maybe I'll watch so you know I'm second
time it's a good time it's the training
helmet
feeling
or suppose together
this looks like cliche but man the scale
of this specific installment everything
looks you can feel how huge
[Music]
how many fights are they gonna have it
was just like what long flower they're
hopping around long have I waited
daddy's are ours
[Music]
you're coming together it is your
undoing this must be right before his
eyes turn red and the other trailer yet
believe see 3px is like an updated or
some kind of modded version
[Music]
Spray like afraid of like a dark side in
her I mean if she looks like she's
experienced evil one these are the
emotions and I feel like that's part of
what could be interesting at the heart
of this trilogy see they're like
fighting them what did see that is
something I'm very curious they're ray
and Heather are striking something down
together yeah that's definitely well you
know how many planets in the Star Wars
universe have frequent flashes of
lightning because we can then try and
really where she is yeah totally
thematically it really seems like it's
dealing a lot with this dark side in ray
that she is ultimately having to
confront and maybe that the day's really
put out something reason if she talked
about how they would acknowledge the the
ray Loewy thing so maybe having more
conversations for kylo Ren is part of
the tempting factor whatever they're
striking down together I know it's like
a lot of this is wonderment of placement
of sequences like is that earlier in the
movie and then they get to that crazy
fight is that crazy fight the last fight
is that like well they're gonna fight
and then she's gonna confront Palpatine
but they're gonna killed he'll be you
know it's like so what something cool
about the marketing for this is it has
been raising so many different kinds of
questions and avenues that this can go
down I'm genuinely it's like I I try to
keep my expectations for this like but
sort of like push push daggers every
time I watch a trailer they go so high
I'm trying to like push them down so I
don't get too overly enthusiastic but I
can't help it when I watch this is like
this looks undeniably gorgeous the scope
this feels like us a war and stars you
know if there's one thing that's
consistent about the Star Wars franchise
it is their marketing because like Star
Wars trailers are always really gorgeous
yeah I really do hope that they I mean
they they always do throw down on
production values the puppets the makeup
all this stuff to make it feel and look
tangible I do think that there is
something that feels a little bigger
about this partly because you do have so
many scenes where yours like wow look at
how huge everything is and look at the
physics ya know cuz especially how like
slow those giant waves are moving and
stuff like that I've been rooting for
Kyle for reloj or whatever for awhile I
think there's something interesting at
the heart of them having this weird
connection from two polar opposite ends
of the force ray it struggles with a lot
of emotions it seems like and so does
kylo Ren and I feel like maybe what this
is leading to is the fact that Rey isn't
quite the quintessential Jedi because
she is dealing with some of this
darkness and you know she is kind of an
orphan unless she turns out to be kylo
Susan yeah and then yeah you have kylo
Ren who's on the opposite side of that
with the dark side not being quite in
line with that either
why is this called rise of Skywalker you
know like you know I've heard the theory
go around that the Skywalker will be the
name for the new that was me saying
trailer might come out behind this whole
thing with Skywalker is does that mean
that they're gonna rename Jedi that
Skywalker's like either way all that
design of clearly where that must be
like Palpatine zli hidden yeah it looks
like Superman's later
it's like Snoke Slayer the first vision
kind of vibe with more claws with like a
Doc Ock situation on the back yeah a
little bit a little bit I I'm so
fascinated my house is going to turn out
I have no idea what's gonna happen
actually I don't know I mean this is the
thing if the Skywalker theory holds true
I feel like you could have a scenario
where Rey and kylo Ren joins somehow and
create a new classification that isn't
so extremely light or extremely dark and
maybe well I know they're a gray Jedi in
the in the extended Star Wars universe I
don't know much about that lore but I
know they exist and I feel like that
would be a cool thing for the movies to
do especially moving into the future
because that's a more nuanced emotional
thing I just love how this is feeling
like so centrally focused on Rey
specifically - yeah but yeah I think is
this one thing to do I think the other
characters I I'm like oh we haven't even
talked about
because they're just kind of there
they're doing in the mission Rose is
there whatever pal potato plant is and
that's in conjunction with kylo Ren and
the big battles going on and the real
personal fight is gonna be going on I
feel like the lightsaber people right
people are in tune with the force we
have it and I think that seemed where
that they keep showing glimpses of when
there when Rey is hugging Leia and then
this trailer she sheds a tear I just
keep thinking that's probably gonna be a
send-off seeing a way to say goodbye or
is it gonna be yeah there's gonna be a
Wiz Khalifa song everything all right
guys so what did you think of this final
trailer do you think this Star Wars will
close out the skywalker saga to the
perfect conclusion that you're waiting
for comment below you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects please click that
notification bell again notify whenever
we've got a youtube video up you can
check us out on the stardust app over
there we do 30 second reaction reviews
for any film TV show and/or trailer we
post daily there's plenty of other a
content creators on there as well but
we're the best I'm just gonna say that
right now completely free to download
and use you can post as well too and of
course I'd like to end this with a page
from the day shout out to a lovely woman
named Rosa Parra Rosa para has recently
joined the cherry-picks what is that
John it's like a female centric Rotten
Tomatoes different perspectives climb it
woke and Rosa has awoken me the force
awakened in me because of You Rosa
you will always be the lady start of our
channel Congrats on the new job that you
actually booked as well you got a lot of
great things going for you at the moment
a lot of great opinions about me I'm so
proud of you I'm so happy for you follow
at Rosa's reviews on the internet she is
one of my favorite human beings in the
world Rosa I love you and if possible I
would love for John to make love to you
shout out done cherry-picks and then you
can review that experience John oh it's
over
and then you could review that
experience